so it's not selfish to put yourself
first so it's self full it's self full
self full to be first to be as good as
possible to you to take care of you be
willing to do a new thing in a new way
and sometimes you're gonna have to piss
people off in the process I give all
meaning to everything I see if I see
myself as broken wounded damaged crazy
stupid whatever I guess meeting two that
need motivation watching top 10 with
belief nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I wanna see explode out onto
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a woman who was born in the back of
a taxicab in Brooklyn New York had a
petty criminal for a father who was
absent from her life and had a mother
who died from breast cancer while she
was four years old to becoming an
inspirational speaker author and TV
personality she's iyanla Vanzant and
here's my take on her top ten roses
success vol 2 joy
[Music]
let's kick things off with rule number
one know who you are you must know who
you are I'm not talking about your name
or your occupation and they're talking
about what people say about you on
Facebook I'm not talking about your PIN
number I'm talking about who you are at
the core and the essence in the root of
your being spiritual code of conduct
says you have to know who you are
and that your behavior cannot make
testimony about you that is not the
truth of who you are when you have a
spiritual code of conduct and when you
know who you are if you ain't know how
you don't act like a ho if you ain't a
deadbeat daddy you don't act like a
deadbeat daddy
if you ain't not gonna you know act like
a guttersnipe come on now you know who
you are
from the inside to the outside and your
behavior is the demonstration of what
you believe to be true about you special
code of conduct
says know who you are when somebody
calls you out your name in your face
rule number two my personal favorite put
yourself first so it's not selfish to
put yourself first so it's self full
itself full self old to be first to be
as good as possible to you to take care
of you to keep you whole and healthy
that doesn't mean that you disregard
everything and everyone but you want to
come with your cup full you know my cup
runneth over what comes out of the cup
is for y'all what's in the cup is mine
but I got it
don't we do that don't we take on other
people's stuff and make it about us when
we don't know that we matter when you
don't know you matter you will make
somebody else's crazy about you you got
your own stuff to handle you don't have
to take on anybody else people violate
you when you don't have clear boundaries
because you don't tell them how to
behave in your life and they run amok
they run amok because you don't have
clear boundaries rule number three is
know your worth real self knows the
truth
no matter what mask or what face you
wear in the world your real self knows
the truth and there was a time in my
life when I acted like I knew a truth
that I didn't know and the truth I
didn't know was the depth of my value
and my worth you see I had already been
an author that had sold over six million
books fourteen different titles I had
already been on my own television show I
had traveled around the world I had
spoken to hundreds of thousands of
people and still I did not know or value
my own worth so and a very big
opportunity to go forward and to beyond
what was once called The Oprah Winfrey
Show yes and I went on The Oprah Winfrey
Show and Miss Winfrey asked me back
again and again and again and eventually
I became part of her change your life
faculty and it was all good I had
written 13 books I had traveled all over
the country I had done her show
repeatedly but I didn't know my own
sense of worth so what happened I tried
to live in a place that I didn't believe
was true for me and eventually I crashed
and burned crashed and burned by leaving
The Oprah Winfrey Show and going on to
another network and doing another show
that didn't even survive a season all
because I didn't know my worth now it
would have looked like all sorts of
external circumstances oh there was a
miscommunication
between me and miss Winfrey and the
other network was offering me a lot of
money and why shouldn't I take a big
business deal no it was about me not
knowing my own words me not being able
to stand in the miracle of being on The
Oprah Winfrey Show repeatedly among
honored teachers without having to work
hard for it because that was what I had
been taught the matter with me was that
I didn't know how to receive a gift a
blessing without working hard for it
so when things came to me easily I blew
him up it's self sabotage or
procrastination or forgetting or
whatever it is that opportunity went
away because I didn't know my worth
that's the kind of truth we have to tell
each other we have to be aware of it we
have to acknowledge it and we have to
accept it
rule number four do not accept the
unacceptable you don't have to be broke
you don't have to struggle you don't
have to be sad and sorry you don't have
to take care of everybody just because
you've always done it be willing to do a
new thing in a new way and sometimes
you're gonna have to piss people off in
the process sometimes those people will
hold you to your limitations they will
hold you to what they believe to be true
about you
spiritual code of conduct says do not
believe that because it hasn't happened
it won't happen renew recharged your
vision and do not be tricked into
thinking that because it's always
happened it has to continue to happen
spiritual code of conduct says do not
accept the unacceptable do not
accommodate and tolerate what doesn't
honor you rule number five is change
your thoughts close your eyes for me for
a moment
and I want you to hear this I give all
me to everything I see breathe I want
you to take that thought out of here
with you so that as you go back into
your life that you remember I give all
meaning to everything I see if I see
myself as broken wounded damaged crazy
stupid whatever I give meaning to that
so if I want my life to have a new
meaning let me pick thoughts and images
that support Who I am
rule number six unpack that baggage when
something happens with a partner or
friend and even a co-worker or or
supervisor and you're bringing up all
the other times that you've experienced
that in the past
that's baggage when you start your
statements about why you do something a
certain way or what you're not gonna do
because of a certain experience that's
baggage and these are just common
everyday things this isn't even the hard
stuff so I want to give you some
unpacking skills for just the common
everyday normal baggage that we walk
around with these human beings if one
person tells you you're a horse you
don't have to believe that if two people
tell you your horse you you may want to
listen but by the time three people tell
you that your horse you need to check
yourself because I bet you got hay
hanging out your mouth and your tail is
wagging in other words if you keep
hearing the same thing from different
people at different times about you you
need to unpack that package and don't
hear it as criticism or make people
wrong or bad
ask them what they mean I remember when
my my grandson told me that I was mean
and I had heard that but I never paid
attention to it because moi I me on the
VIN said I can't be mean but when I sat
and I listened to him and I realized
wait a minute he's not the only one
saying that to me I had to hear it and I
had to unpack it so when you hear one or
two or three unrelated people telling
you the same thing don't dismiss that
aspect tell me more about that because
there may be some baggage that I have to
unpack rule number seven ask for what
you want you have to ask for what you
want and don't settle for what's
available or what you think you can get
say it again they told me say it again a
spiritual code of conduct says that you
have to ask for what you want and do not
settle for something because it's all
you think you can have or because it's
what's available if you want it single
don't settle for it if it's married
let me take a walk if you want it easy
don't make it hard and if you want it
hard then you gotta work with it if it's
not
[Applause]
ask for what you want and ask for the
things that are gonna up level your
wattage in life don't set off the things
that are going to dim your light
I'm level your wattage sometime I like
be bright blinding us your light is so
brilliant it blinds you the reflection
of its shiny back in your eye and so you
get confused and you'll beat a holding
on the things that do not reflect your
own brilliance did you hear what I said
that's your light your gift your talent
your truth can be so brilliant that it
blinds you and you end up reaching out
for holding on to taking on taking care
of housing feeding clothing lending
money to stuff that only dims your life
rule number eight is trust yourself
often we teach preach say what we most
need to learn what was it about trust
that you needed to learn for yourself
I grew up thinking that a woman was my
mother who was not I grew up thinking
that there was something wrong with me
because of god only knows why my life
will you explain why so well in reading
about your grandmother I think she was
related to my god in all the ways that
you make children feel inadequate yeah I
was bad yeah I was bad yeah I had to
devil in me yeah had the devil in me and
she was gonna beat it out because she
was a woman who because of the times in
which she was raised and the suppression
and oppression had learned that it was
best to go through the world keeping
quiet keep quiet
be
they want you to be how do i knuckle
down had I really given in to the
restrictions and limitations placed on
me I wouldn't be Who I am today was my
talking that saved me here was the you
know the classic shut up you talk too
much
shut up why you talk so much you've
always got something to say
and today people pay me well hear me
speak yeah if I had shut up as a child
that may not have never had so you
learned that you needed to learn to
trust yourself rule number nine use
feedback to improve even when it doesn't
feel good
feedback can be a really really good
thing but first I want us to make a
distinction between feedback and
criticism because I think that's
important feedback is the energy or the
return energy of what's put out this
means that feedback is information about
or reactions to our state of being and
our performance in our our way of being
in relationship feedback comes to us as
a response or a reaction or sometime as
comments or a review of what we do and
how we show up at any given moment and
feedback has a purpose the purpose of
feedback is to provide us with guidance
or direction that will serve as the
influence for modification or change in
our behavior and in our energy so in
other words feedback is a cue that's
something we do or say or how we behave
needs to change that's all it is now
that sounds pretty harmless but but here
comes the challenge most feedback either
feels or sounds critical which means
that it's gonna trigger a toxic memory
or a feeling which then motivates us to
discount the feedback we're receiving
you know we can't even hear it so so
what is criticism man
if feedback is criticism of what is
criticism criticism is feedback that
demoralizes condemns judges or blames
it's feedback that is consciously or
unconsciously offered to manipulate or
control that's the difference where
feedback is offered to motivate
correction or change criticism is
offered to manipulate and control and in
many many cases while what people offer
as constructive criticism what they want
to give us it actually criticizes us and
that's what leads to a mental or
emotional shutdown and we can lose the
value of what's being offered because
criticism is our offering now here's the
good news all criticism is feedback and
here's the bad news all criticism is
feedback what I mean is this whether
it's positive or negative productive or
unproductive all feedback is telling you
something you need to know about
yourself and what you hear and how you
hear it has nothing to do with who's
saying it all feedback is about who you
be and how you be and it's bringing that
to your awareness there's something you
need to change beloved whether it is
coming at you from your mother or your
sister or your boss or your coworker or
your partner feedback is a source of
information for self improvement and it
can be received and used as the
foundation for altering and changing
your way of being or specific course of
behavior and rule number 10 the last one
before the bonus clips have a morning
routine do you have a morning ritual oh
yes
absolutely soon as my eyes open 23rd
song as soon as my eyes open I'd do it
and then I usually go I go sage my house
out cuz I don't know what was floating
around in there in the night cuz you
know I live out in the bushes like you
then I make my coffee and I do love my
morning coffee and then I read my my
Course in Miracles lesson for the day I
read my Jesus calling mmm-hmm and then I
put my Bible to my head and open it and
wherever it opens that's what I mean and
then I go downstairs and sometimes I get
on the treadmill and sometimes I just
dust it off I always get on my
trampoline uh-huh and do my 15 minutes
there uh-huh and then I get on my
inversion table and I hang upside down
yeah yeah because the rust of bloods of
my head and keep me from getting
wrinkled and then I'm off for my day
now I've got some special Iyanla bonus
cuts for you but before that my question
of the day for you is what is your
morning routine what is a single thing
that you have to do every single morning
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
do ground yourself spiritually every day
that means when you get up in the
morning connect with something bigger
greater grander than you ground yourself
spiritually every day
that means believe in trust in connect
to something bigger than you something
grander something more divine something
that makes your divinity worthwhile if
you don't you can be knocked off Center
by everything that comes your way we've
all had that experience where it just
seems that we're not moving we're
holding on or we're no matter what we do
it doesn't seem to be advancing us this
is what we call the experience of being
stuck of not being able to move or
manifests or Express or experience that
which we desire to do being stuck is
both a mental experience and emotional
experience and sometimes a physical
experience and there are three reasons
that we get stuck number one we really
don't know who we are when you don't
know who you are you don't know what you
are capable
and you get stuck in your limited
perceptions of yourself and reality
number two when you don't want to find
out who you are and you won't take the
risk to push yourself beyond what you
know and when you are stuck on your
story stuck on your sadness just stuck
on being stuck you don't want to know
who you are so you won't push yourself
you'll stay where it's comfortable
you'll stay where it's familiar boy will
you be stuck and the other reason that
we get stuck is because we live down to
other people's expectations of us how
many times have we been told as children
you can't do that don't do that
you can't do that you won't do that they
won't let me and we believe that and we
stay stuck raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that that
people passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on Europe it's
suppose to mean I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link the
description for details